kind of felt bad when i saw that i woke
up every day saw connor doing this and
i'm like yeah i'm gonna stream genting
today
it's just like yeah stream get you for
seven hours
i'm worse i didn't listen
i'm worse than you at least you were
like yeah i might you know also stream
you know i i wasn't even like i wasn't
even like you know what i might even
stream i was just like no i'm not even
gonna stream i'm just gonna
sit back and just enjoy myself it's just
me i just like doing like crazy
things that push the the envelope with
you i don't know what is that the first
thing yeah yeah therefore why why does
it push the envelope what the [ __ ] i
don't know i don't know i don't know
i don't know like i wanted to do
something crazy on twitch yeah i have
like a big event and i wanted to do
something that was like you know that
hadn't really been seen a lot on twitch
i don't know i've done it before but i
wanted to do it in like a way that was
really unique gamified yeah yeah i just
i just wanted to make it hype and um i
like pushing the boundaries of what you
can do on live streams and i think his
stuff was like interesting i don't know
i'm like addicted to making stuff i
guess
you're just you're addicted to content
yeah i think i think we're all addicted
to content in one way shape or form
i love playing games but i'm like man
you know nobody in my head i'm like man
nobody nobody remembers that guy who
just [ __ ] played games unless you're
a markiplier you know what i mean
to be honest if i feel like if you're
not addicted like if we weren't addicted
to content i don't think we would have
lasted this long
yeah because like that's at the end of
the day that's what it is like the
people who last longer than not are the
ones who are like constantly just trying
to push themselves to do
bigger and better things people always
ask like you know worry that if we're
gonna get burnt out or i'm gonna get
burnt out i'm just like well no i kind
of get like sad when i'm not making
stuff i really feel fulfilled and happy
when i'm making stuff it's good stuff
and it's rewarding i get burnt out if i
just make stuff i i always need a
constant this is the next big projects
that you are
going to be doing and working towards
and i noticed i think that's the one
thing we all have in common where i know
what my big my next big project is and
i'm sure like you guys like we're we're
constantly planning different things
both together and now individually as
well yeah so it's it's it's it's weird
and i guess that's like
it's it's great actually uh having you
guys as friends because i see you doing
this i'm like [ __ ] now i gotta get on my
ass and do something exciting
and do something and do something what
it is it's just like it's just like
constantly having
the next goal yeah to reach and then
once you've reached that goal yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then once you've reached
that goal then there's that new goal and
then there's a new goal and you go and
just keeps on cycling but like the bros
just keep you on your toes you know
it does it's like being spotted you know
he's just like come on come on you can
benches
one more one more one more you got this
you got this i'm obsessed with the idea
of doing like some kayaking stream i
really want to do a kayaking show i'm
not for kayaking yeah i just but
do you know what's the one thing though
that you really have to be careful of
the kayaking stream if you fall off the
kayak oh yeah yeah it's ripper yeah like
yeah your stream is [ __ ] yeah at least
with alice at least you're on land on a
bicycle they're
they're like i i was thinking about how
you could maybe have so like i had to
expect when it was raining yeah i had to
kind of have something waterproof yeah
uh it was like it worked but obviously
it won't work if you submerge it yeah
it's splash proof but i i know that some
people make these plastic housings for
the stuff i wondered if you could make
it kind of well i mean there's those
like plastic housings for like uh big
cameras you know underwater shooting and
stuff so you should have the wire come
out of it kind of somehow exactly yeah
so there would have to be the whole
thing basically
as well yeah but the wire length would
have that that seems like a technique a
lot of challenges but uh yeah you
probably need to be 3d printed or some
[ __ ] like that probably but it could be
i would want to do a kayaking stream
kind of like maybe the same deal you do
that distance i think you're pretty hype
sure just kayaking all day yeah same the
honest thing is it would be super
[ __ ] boring kayaking if you unless
you had like a really sick lake
you would need to have like a really
interesting route yeah i feel like yeah
yeah yeah but dude kayaking i think he's
fun as [ __ ] though it's awesome but i
know that like your feet get [ __ ]
after a while because you've just been
like in the wet kayak after a while yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah maybe like a day thing i could do
it uh it could be pretty high i i kind
of want to figure out how to do it um um
maybe someday i'll figure out how to
yeah i try to do more interesting irl
stuff like i had a i had a
a theory that you could set it up this
way and i never ended up doing it just
because i was so tired every day
i had so the way that the backpack works
you can put like a mic into the back of
the camera and you put a lap mic so i
had this big brain idea i was like wait
my cable's long enough where if you put
the bag in the back of the car and then
put a suction cup on the back of the car
with a camera mount you could feed the
camera that's in the bags in the car you
could feed the camera with the wire onto
the suction cup behind you you're you're
wearing a lav mic and then you could be
have the car trail you
really oh
like a third person camera and then you
could have literally like a like a
third-person view of you with the mic on
you and it would be streaming how sick
would that look
i thought man that would be so cool to
do that'd be like that'd be like if you
had your regular streaming setup but it
was moving yeah kind of yeah it's
literally like marching like the problem
is that like
you'd have to do it in a place like if
we would have done it we would have done
it on the first few days you'd need like
a road that was empty yeah to try it
well so i just want to [ __ ] around and
set it all up it was such a big hassle
yeah maybe if i prepared more i could
have done it but it was a lot of prep
but i thought it'd be a sick idea
or you got something for next time yeah
i could try it next time if i have more
time if we have like a day where we
don't have as much going on yeah but
like a lot of the time google maps
wouldn't send you down the right route
yeah probably not google that's so
annoying
that just didn't well like
okay so here's the thing google maps
works perfectly i find in the city but
you go to a country that might not be as
well developed or go to an area that is
you know not as you know a bit more
rural you know out and out of the city
and google maps does not work as
efficiently as you think it does at all
it would just like especially when
you're you've clicked the cycling option
yeah it would just like tell you to get
off the highway not how i like just a
main road yeah for like one minute to go
via like a round in a field and then
join back and it's like why for one
minute it's like why would you why would
you think i'd want to do that i'll just
stay because google's like we know you
want the scenic route because it
generally wants you not to be on a main
road which is good because sometimes it
took us down some really cool routes
yeah because we trusted it but other
times it would take us down a road maybe
just gravel and we couldn't cycle on it
right because the bikes the road yeah i
i remember i encountered this problem a
lot in uh thailand yeah oh god yes
because
because what what what i would do is you
know
google maps you know works in thailand
but what counts as a road on google maps
google maps can't tell you the quality
of the roads
google maps use like open maps and open
maps is from like i don't know like
government i don't know yeah i don't
know because like what happens is uh
we'd like when i was living in thailand
me and sydney would like have a
destination sometimes it'll be like an
hour away or something like a different
town and go and we'd be on like the
highway with signs telling us to lead to
this town or the city that we wanted to
go to and google was like no take take
the exit off here and one time we're
like okay why is it telling us to take
the exit off maybe there's maybe there's
a shortcut we don't know about and then
so we went from this very well-lit road
we take one exit off and google leads us
to it's it's
the definition of a road was pushed to
the limits okay what it led to
was
not even like concrete it was just dirt
leading into a dark forest that's right
and there wasn't we couldn't even go
back right because time in the country
yeah first time yeah because it was like
it was like it was on a mountain right
it was on a mountain so we couldn't even
you turn back so we we were forced to
like go into like this pitch black
forest and i was like i'm gonna get
murdered this is this is literally the
start of every horror movie i've seen in
my life you know you you follow google
maps you're like oh okay what's this uh
going a bit to the country this is where
the serial killers live man this is like
texas chainsaw massacre all over again
we had that though uh yesterday when me
and nabi went we were in shizuoka
yesterday for a shoot and like we were
trying to go to this like you know
because like for the most part it's like
country sign shizuoka yeah and we're
like i want like a really like nice spot
to like shoot this part of the video
and so we were like alright we'll put it
in google maps and then i was like okay
go down this road and i was like okay
that's fine we get to it
first of all it's a one-way road in
between two houses
barely can fit the car that we have
and it's not even the right way
and the google maps is like
do it
go there is no other way to go down to
your destination go down this road right
now and we had no choice because there
was like cars backed up yeah yeah
literally no other road to get through
this part i'm like
why are we going down so what you want
us to like break traffic laws to get to
our destination thanks google
it's so annoying it's so annoying and
it's like and when you try and be like
okay we can't go down this road can you
try something else they're like okay how
about you go around the block once
and try it again
i was like no girl
i don't want to go down this road i
think for all the information they take
from us too yeah maps accurate they at
least do a [ __ ] good job
like it's like well it's because not
enough people are living there further
yeah there's no information to take
you know for the the comfort of having a
map that could tell me where to go i'd
like to think that you know you taking
everything about me and using that
information to serve ads to me is at
least you know at least i got a good map
out of it like google's that one mate
that's like sitting in the passenger
seat being like yeah don't worry about
it
don't worry about it it's the quickest
way to go it's like are you sure yeah
yeah yeah i know this place i've made it
before don't worry it's down there one
thing i've got to mention is that yeah
having a car that rides with you is very
op and cycling oh yeah definitely
because you don't have to worry about
like water or anything it's all taken
care of you're all talking about the
back of the car shout out to the chads
who do it all themselves i don't know
how to do it i just
well their backpack is probably insane
it's probably full of water they don't
have the tech on them so they can fill
up with actual uh things needed uh to uh
to keep their body going right yeah yeah
exactly i guess so
stopping at kombini's and then there's
like none in north hokkaido as well yeah
true yeah true so sorry to talk about
just the cycling so much i guess i just
[ __ ] all i did was that for eight
days yeah that's all i could think about